hallo mein name ist klug und herzlich
willkommen wir heute meine lieben
freunde zur mittlerweile schon siebte
nicht lachen challenge allerdings nicht
nur mit mir sondern auch mit shakespeare
teilt die geister aus deutschland mehr
braucht man dazu glaube ich gar nicht
sagen wir starten mit den videos magst
du der villen links laden aufmachen
die kräfte der wind kräftig mit klagen
können in köln auf der kreuzstraße
also ich möchte ich auf keinen fall
altern ist ende aber guck mal erst
gesagt er kriegt man sich genau bestimmt
denselben leo manch alter ich wage es zu
bezweifeln
bei 25 grad jetzt mal zu tragen sondern
wird hier umgedrehten münster und das ja
ja es wird mir vorgeworfen ich finde sie
war so krass wie die dann so
verschiedene silben anders betont als
das muttersprachliche machen weiß wie
ich meine mutter macht das auch so dass
die er damit ja damit so die
konzentration verwendet seine seine
argumente sind er bringt sie alle
argumente an dann so du weißt ich trage
man das ist so das argument
[Musik]
vor allem das letzte so durch die
würstchen fresser wer sagt denn du
würstchen fresser was ist so die
krasseste beleidigung wie du gerade so
parat hat aber die so ein bisschen
kreativ auch ist das aber klemmte
abgemahnte alles klar kommst du klar da
hinten im wieder fällt ich sag jetzt ok
und den möchte so möchte ich bitte auf
englisch übersetzt haben okay ich
bereite mich auf mein name ist sandra
und ich habe kein abitur unter punkt
- 100 punkte er seine telefonnummer
kriegen ich alle wieder so dunkel dass
ich 100 prozent
die man per vor richtig aufträgt du
nimmst das papier ein hinters ohr
zweiter hinter das ohr einen offenen
graben zweiten offenen fragen im
hinterkopf obwohl das auch jeden tag ein
hemd tragen länder ich würde eine auf
dem klagewege wieder in meinem
schlafzimmer einen geraden zeiten auch
einen plan b hat dieses wunderschöne
bild sondern eure dana an die jungs
unter euch weiß bescheid bilderrahmen
ein paket über die dicke ringe und dann
gibt dem lot karotin allerdings anderer
soeben kam ja auch eine neue podcast
folge online auf unserem kanal richtig
ja und was haben wir darin so gesagt
werden die folge ist in 8 d aufgenommen
ja leute im heutigen podcast haben wir
mal selber 8d audio ausprobiert also
einen link zu der neuen podcast folge
findet ihr selbstverständlich und in der
infobox oder gebt einfach dick und doof
über allein bei spotify apple musikwoche
man podcast kann und auf einem zweit
kanal ist soeben auch ein neues video
online gegangen und dort habe ich
nämlich auch mit acht die audio
rumgespielt das video findet ihr hier
verlinkt oder auch unten in der
apropos verschaffe ich war beim friseur
zudem nach hause gefahren
2 mm hoch im kurs wider
manchmal haben wir nehmen uns zu mir
sagt springmann nacht in ein gehege
wohnende grizzly bear machen bevor der
satz zu ende bringe ich rein abstand für
die kranken ausgesprochen petition
sandra was war dein rapper name wenn du
so richtig zu sozialen web machen
würdest hat ein gutes gesicht minimales
gewicht denn ein minimales gewicht haben
das ist party bruder erkennst noch party
bruder nein na gut
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
also hat angst von mir das kann ich
wirklich da hat angst vor ihm
dazu wieder tausende wanderer auch
richtig sandra wieder gewissen die
konnte einfach nicht mehr sprechen
sprachen lernen ein schwanz gewinnt hast
du nicht gesehen wie toll man hinter mir
herzlich total doof ich und superman
schlicht mein schwanz kann sogar super
verstehen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
oder er war sehr gut der anfang auch
hier nicht sozial aber zum schluss
dieses es raus die kitze bis zum schluss
dieses zeigt doch schon zeitung kurina
wie man noch von seiner hände
desinfiziert lieblingsklubs plötzlich
aber es ist ja richtig klasse alkohol
drin
ja sagt er sind fix du dich jeden tag
von den mit wodka
meine oma trinkt wirklich ihnen abend
einen schnaps
ganz wichtig ist ohne diese geht nicht
immer so so fing an der guten tag auch
ich habe mir nach geschlagen
aber das war noch gar nicht alles ist
sie ist auch schwanger ich werde wir
haben so lange nicht mehr auf filmen wie
reagiert lukas stimmt wir müssen uns mal
wieder eine folge anschauen dann bot
darauf leute dann lass mal daumen hoch
beim video dazu gesagt auf wiedersehen
noch so geht das nicht
wie bereits gesagt ich war heute beim
einem gehört zu hause und hat mir dort
die haare geschnitten und ich habe mich
mit ihm auch so war das ganze thema gar
aktuell unterhalten auch vor allem mit
jims die angeschlossen und herzlich so
ein trampolin bestellt sag mal was
denkst du wie teuer war dieses kleine
trampe tätig sagte ganz ehrlich bestimmt
200 628 euro für ein kleines trampolin
sander du machst aber auch gerade mal
hott naja ich hab gestern gesagt und ich
bin aktuell seit gestern noch wie auf
diät ich habe schon ein paar tage durch
kite ich wollte sagen das ist ja schon
zehn mal so lang wie deine letzte diät
ich habe gestern noch aus versehen ein
snickers eis gegessen aber das sehen wir
nicht dass das thema einfach nicht dazu
gedacht ist ja ist ja auch ist ja auch
gesund quasi schokolade ist ja noch so
stimmt ja es stimmt dass er gesund und
gut als wenn er so schnell hilfe holen
zum anderen mcdonald's trend um den kopf
nein merkels die sache dann geht es zum
anderen musste ich einfach nur um zu
zeigen dass ich damit deutlich wo er
gerade ist
aber ihr trotzdem da ist versteht was er
meint nein
er kaufte die sache meinem ein mcdonalds
nimmt die sachen und geht es um andere
mcdonald's um dem imac dort zu zeigen
dass er nicht gut ist direkt zum ja kein
win einfach und an der stelle durch das
heute wieder sauber werden meine lieben
freunde wenn euch diese mittlerweile
schon 17 nicht lachen challenge zusammen
mit seiner gefallen ist dann das gerne
einen daumen hoch unter dem video hier
das schaffen wir 40.000 likes auf jeden
fall mega kreislandwirt und zeigen ihr
feiert das ganze sandra wie geht es dir
gerade so überhaupt gut gut und bei uns
geklingelt deswegen bände jetzt videos
ihr findet jetzt die oberin smiley
eingeblendet werden darauf könnt ihr
kostenlos main kanal abonnieren ich habe
fast keine videos mehr und hier ist das
video von dem ich zu beginn dieses
videos hier schon geredet habe und zwar
das video auf meinem zweiten kanal wo
ich achte audio ausprobiert das habe ich
auch immer neuen podcast folge gemacht
die ist auf spotify apple podcasts etc
online inc auch dazu in der beschreibung
ca